foreign
today we will take you through the hands
of lab demo of how you can do a Market
Basket analysis using python before we
start I hope the screen is clearly
visible and the audio is fine if yes
please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them I am
repeating again before we start I hope
the screen is clearly visible and the
audio is fine if yes please type in yes
if there are any issues do let us know
in the chat section so that we can
resolve them
let's wait for some more minute to let
other people join
until then let me tell you guys that we
have regular updates on multiple
Technologies
if you are a tech geek on a continuous
hunt for the latest technological Trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
learn
I'm repeating again let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek on a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
great I think we can get started
so in today's session we will go through
Market Basket analysis after that a hand
software demo of Market Basket analysis
will be done using Python and machine
learning
we will perform different function and
different python libraries before we
move on to the programming part let's
discuss what Market Basket analysis
first and proceed further for the same
so what is Market Basket analysis
retailer utilized Market Basket analysis
a data mining approach to boost sales by
better understanding client byte
patterns large data sets such as
purchase histories must be analyzed to
identify products groups and items that
are most likely to be bought together
so dear Learners if you want to upskill
your AI and machine learning skills so
give yourself a chance to Simply learn
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with
completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course details from the
description box below
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you exactly one minute for
this you can comment or you can give
your answer in the chat section so I can
see if the answer is given by you are
right or wrong so the question is
which is the best language for machine
learning Java
C C plus plus python
let us know your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section
do let me know your answer please
so I am starting timer of one minute
so as time starts now
which is the best language for machine
learning Java C C plus plus or python
you can type your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section
to let me know your answer please
I kindly ask that everyone should take
part in this
which is the best language for machine
learning Java C C plus plus or python
30 seconds more
let us know your answer in the comment
section
which is the best language for machine
learning Java C C plus plus or python
15 seconds more
which is the best language for machine
learning Java C C plus plus or python
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this
five seconds more
Those Who provided the current response
will receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one now let's move to our
programming part to do Market Basket
analysis using python
so first we will open command prompt to
write a command to open Jupiter notebook
so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here I will select new
python zip file
so this is the how the Jupiter notebook
UI look likes so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in analyzing the data so
here I will write import
numpy
s n b
and the second one is
import
pandas
as PD
and and the third one is import
C bone
as SNS
and the fourth one is import
matplotlib
dot PLT
sorry dot Pi plot
as PLT
PLT
so number is for linear algebra and that
pandas is for data preprocessing
and C bone required for plotting and
matplotlib also is required for plotting
so the first one numpy number is a
python Library used for working with
arrays it also has function for working
in the domain of lineal algebra and
matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely numpy stand for numerical
python
so the next Library responders panda is
a software liability written for the
Python programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis
in particular it offers data structure
and operators for manipulating numerical
tables and Time series
and C bone an open source python Library
based on matplotlib is called C bone it
is utilized for data exploration and
data visualization
with data frames and the pandas Library
C bone functions with ease
for Python and its numerical extension
numpy matplotlib is a cross platform for
data visualization and GUI as a result
it represents a strong open source
suitable for Matlab the apis for
metrolip allows programming to
incorporate graphs into giu applications
so after importing libraries let's
import data set for that I will write
here this I will rename this
Market
basket
okay so here I will write
DF equals to PD
dot read
underscore CSU
then file name
here I will write groceries
underscore data set
dot CSV
okay
and here I will write DF Dot
head
then press enter
yeah
so here PD is for pandas Library read is
used for reading the data set from the
machine and CSV is used for the type of
file which we want to read
so
then DF dot head if you want top five
rows of your data set you can use head
and if you want last five rows of your
data set you can use tail instead of
head so here you can see member number
date and item description Okay so
moving forward let's check data type
information for validation purposes
so here I will write DF Dot
info
okay then press enter
so pandas data frame dot info function
is used to get concise summary of the
data frame
it comes really handy when doing
exploitative analysis of the data to get
a quick overview of the data set we use
the data frame dot info function
so here you can see column names no null
count and data types okay
then you here you can see the memory
uses
so moving forward
let's check availability of
I repeat let's check availability of
null values for that we will write here
DF Dot is null
DF dot is none
and brackets
dot sum
and Dot sort values
in ascending order
ascending
question
false
okay then press enter
so no null values
so some calculate the sum of elements
for each row and column since
therapy since some calculate as 2 equals
to 1 and false is equal to 0. you can
count the number of missing values in
each row and column by calling sum from
the result of Isner
You Can Count missing values in each
column by default and in each row with X
is equals to 1. okay
then here you can see sort values
so sort values is used for sort values
in ascending or descending order okay so
moving forward let's do type conversion
from object to data type
okay so here
I will write
DF
date
okay this is sorry TF
day of date
equals to PD Dot
to date time
okay
then again I have to write here DF
data sorry date
then press enter
then again I will write DF dot info
and press enter
okay ignore These Warnings
so
so the type conversion is done
so moving forward let's do some schema
check for that we will write we have Dot
at
okay all seems fine I hope you
understand till here if you have any
question or any queries regarding any
code or any question just put us in
comments our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution I'm repeating
again I hope you understand till here if
you have any question or any queries
regarding any code or question just put
us in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution
okay so moving forward let's create
distribution of item sold
for that
I will write here item item
underscore distribution
equals to
DF dot Group by
then
y equals to
item description
okay
dot size
then dot reset
underscore index
name equals to
frequency
okay I will write here dot sort
underscore
values
by
take question
frequency
20
okay here f is also capital
then in ascending order
sending equals to
pause
and here I will write dot head
then
here I will give 10.
okay then enter
so now I will declare some variables so
here I will write bars
equals to
item underscore
distribution
okay then
item
description
okay then
height
equals to
item underscore distribution
okay then here's
20
.
then X underscore for position equals to
NP dot margin
uh okay not margin I will write here
arrange
then length of bars
length of bars
so here I will Define
okay for better View
I will do here
yep that's good
okay so we will Define here figure size
so for that I will write PLT dot figure
then figure size
equals to
16 comma 9.
okay
so we will create bars so PLT Dot
bar
X position
comma height
comma color
collect question
I will do 0.2 comma 0.3
comma 0.5
comma 0.5
okay
so
everything is done let me set the title
PLT Dot
title
like
top
10 sold
item
then X labels Realty Dot
X label
right item name
then available
like number of quantity sold
quantity sold
okay
so let me do PLT Dot
like create names on the like x axis
okay
X takes
then
X underscore position
comma bars
okay then PLT Dot
sure
but then press enter
okay NP arrange numpy has no attribute
as a range
okay here is spelling mistake so sorry
yeah
so here you can see the top 10 Soul item
but your whole make other vegetable
rolls and burns soda then yogurt
till this citrus fruit so these are in
descending order okay
moving forward let's set date as index
as index plotting purpose okay
for that I will write here
DF underscore date
the
equals to TF
Dot set underscore
index
date
okay
DF unless one date
then press enter
okay so here you can see all the dates
and the member number and the item
description
okay so date is set
so I hope you understand till here like
if you have any question or any query
regarding any code
a question just put us in comments our
team will shortly provide you the
correct solution
okay I'm repeating again I hope you
understand till here if you have any
question or any doubt please comment
down the below our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution
so moving forward let's make a graph
again okay another graph so DF
underscore date
Dot resample
then
here I will write medium m
then item description
item description
dot count
Dot Plot
trigger size
equals to
20 point
20 comma eight
okay
so let me continue here
let's do it
here I will write grid
equals to
through
then let me set the title
that is equals to
okay number of
number
of item
sold by month
okay
then comma
that
let me do dot set
11
X11
question
that's good
date
and viable
person
number of
item
sold
okay
so code is looking okay so let me run
this
so press enter
so yeah
so here you can see the number of items
sold by a month okay
so you can see the graph
so moving forward we will select only
required variable for modeling and
removing white space if any
for that I have to write here
I will let her count
sorry
I will write here
customer level
equals to DF
okay then
remember
number
comma
item
description
okay
Dot
sort
values
by
the question
number
so I will write here
member number
okay
then comma
standing
question
pause
then
like customer
level
equals to not equal to this time
item description
okay then equals to
customer level
then
item
description
Str Dot
zip
then
HTML level
okay
so press enter
so yeah okay so yeah so everything is
good and fine so let's move forward and
combine all the items in the list format
for each customer so for that I will
write here
transactions
equals to
a
1 uh
right item
description
dot to list
okay
so here I will write for
a in list
then
11
Dot
Group by
then here I will write member
number
okay
then press enter
okay okay okay sorry
forget
yeah and press enter
so now let's import a Priory package for
the model creation
here I will write
from
the purity
import
a
writing okay
so so here I will write rules
equals to
a priority
transactions
equals to
transaction
comma like minimum support
equals to 0.02
okay now 0.002
then comma
minimum confidence should be
equal to 0.05
okay then minimum lift
equals to 3.
then minimum length
equals to 2.
okay
so this is for the model creation
okay rules
equals to
invariance and maybe you've meant equals
your question
instead of
okay
okay forget
here's the thing
for over two
yeah then pressing
yeah so moral creation is done so moving
forward let's store result in the list
format for better visuals and let's see
the results okay so here I will write
results
equals to list
of
rules
and press enter
then
results
press enter
so it's loading
still loading this will take some time
still loading taking some time
so let me restart and run on
so press enter
yeah
so here you can see the results
so now repeat
so like kitchen Towers like USD milk and
potato products be meat spreads
automatic X so these are these
examples so moving forwards creating
user defined function for arranging the
results okay in proper manner so obtain
from model and readable format
so here I will write for that
DF question inspect
results
okay
for that
LGS equals to
double
then results
then two
zero
then again 0
okay
so here I will write 0 again
for results
for result and results
then rhs
sorry rhs
equals to
let me copy from here
and I will make the edits
okay instead of 0 I will put here one
okay
then supports
a question
so results
one
for
result and result
now confidence
result
to
zero
to
well
result
in
results
and
ellipse
equals to
result
to
then
zero
three
four
result
and results
okay
then lift is complete
then I will add return
list
zip
LHS
I don't know
why it says
supports
comma
confidence
confidence is comma lift
lifts
okay
then
I will write here result
s
in
data frame
goes to PD Dot
data frame
packed
results
comma
column
question
left hand side
okay comma then
right hand side
okay then comma
support
then come off
confidence
confidences
comma
lift
okay
press enter so now I will run it
so here light result
in data frame
okay f is come on
Dot and largest
and largest
then n equals to
10
comma
problems
person
left
okay
yeah
so here you can see the the best
possible scenarios okay then kitchen
Towers USD milk these are the some
recommendation when the customer will
buy this so these are the recommendation
that
he or she also buy this okay
so I hope you are understand till here
if you have any questions or any query
regarding any code or question just put
us in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution I hope
you guys must have understood how you
can do Market based basket analysis
using python if you have any queries you
can ask in the comment section below our
team will respond you as soon as
possible and don't forget to check the
course link from the description box
below and if you want this full code
just comment for the same thank you so
much for being here if you enjoyed this
video please do subscribe to our YouTube
channel and give a like to this video
thank you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here